what is this like you guys are doing
press together yeah bromance what's
going on yeah I mean I guess you could
call it a bromance we just you know I
think me and Daniel always gravitated
towards each other on these shows
because we kind of where we are who we
are you know we we do you know show it
and like we don't lie we don't you know
talk stuff behind people's back
everything we pretty much talk is pretty
much out in the open I know that's why
you know this is saying real recognizes
real and I think that's why we became
pretty good pals over these last couple
months it was you know you're in these
experiences where you know you're cut
off from the outside world and you
really tend to form great you know long
lasting relationships even if it was a
guy or a girl but I mean when you do
show us some money you have a lot in
common and it's a big experience and now
that we've done forward it shows
together it's huge we have yeah we're
both laid-back we both like have a laugh
and we don't take it too serious so
that's why we're able to get along and
things are you know we have a good time
and don't you think he's more attractive
because he's Canadian of course
yeah he's China I marry music and yeah
yeah I was trying to setup them out you
know baby
well I talked to Jeff how about a Justin
Trudeau better day and I said hey he get
Vinny into the countryside yeah no
problem he's like you look like Justin
Trudeau kind of I mean yeah I mean I can
I just interject looking guy so I guess
if you want to call you know my look
like sure why not
are you going to be watching bachelor
canada um I will probably be watching
bachelor Canada I find you know I hate
to say it but why did the reality on a
lot of shows reality TV shows they can
be often a little bit more you know
whenever I used to watch them back in
the day I'd always like you know come on
people be give us give me something to
laugh at be crazy be silly this is a TV
you know and so and I knew if I were
ever get on TV I wanted to entertain and
so I find [ __ ] but both of us on
bachelor Canada Bachelorette kind of a
yeah I mean I know if I work but I mean
fight over the same girl away you sure
we're gonna be fun listen make a my
anyway that'll be fun I think it's going
to be the next Bachelor
I mean I think I've heard that what
Daniel McGuire might be that hey oh yeah
there's word on the street
we're going to try and do like a dual
bachelor and then like the girls have to
vote like he did already on one of the
other seasons no but I think I think
Peter I think Peter should be the next
Bachelor that you've got a great head on
her shoulders he's not afraid to put
foot down in situations like with Rachel
he didn't want to get engaged and I and
I respect him for saying that because
he's not going to get engaged just
because people thinks that's the right
thing to do or that's what you're
supposed to do you know you gotta follow
your heart if your heart says no I don't
feel it doesn't feel right then I'm not
gonna do it right so that's being real
that's what I respected someone even I
didn't see the season and I don't
anything know what a guy I don't know
anything about them um what okay you're
a fire a barber right
former yeah former sometimes he
sometimes didn't shave my back yeah I
get I get his neck hairs back here yeah
hook him up
what do you think of Robbie's here oh
yeah I mean when you think about it I
mean is it he could use a little trim
but if he likes it that I'm you know I'm
happy for him Bagon
no I mean these he's getting a little
mad at me lately for a couple comments
and oh wow hey he's getting mad at for
just getting mad I don't know
everybody's getting mad stuff with me
would be a lot of you were just too
sensitive you know and yeah it had to do
with being insecure sign and it is what
it is I think if he likes his hair that
way then
bless his heart there never makes you
happy right he's gonna do member michy
on me now okay I got to go back to the
Corinne and tamari Oh thing it wasn't
quote that I read just this morning so
all I want to do it was a thing about we
don't out Koran oh here we go
wait there me Trevizo what did I say oh
he really well the art and on that
Curran you that she is wine yes
yeah so what was the what was it about
we were talking about how you she went
she went up to oh oh yeah she's going to
create about yes Ukraine was talking to
Chris Harrison about being in a
relationship or not and Chris Harrison
said I do have a boyfriend and she said
no and I'm like what I just I hate liars
and people like that do that sort of
thing and I just despise of it so I just
video and a lyin lyin sack of
yeah maybe I should have used overs but
you know it's being honest a real and
that's how I feel I know it's hard not
it's I'm being myself and so if you
don't like it too bad you know and
that's just what I think you know it's
why you going on the show if you have a
boyfriend I mean obviously you're going
to be going on for not the right reasons
and I'm not saying I'm an angel or
anything that but leave some single at
least I'm you know trying to find
someone I am going there for fun and
experience and to get a vacation and
whatever whatever else you know but I'm
a girlfriend so have you well obviously
you touches Mario now but have you
talked to Demario or Curran since this
whole thing happen I've chatted with
Corinne just you know basic stuff I
didn't want to ask her about the TV show
stuff because I think that's probably
what everybody's been asking I'm just
I've been friends with her before you
know coming back for Paradise she lives
in Florida so every why so it was
nothing to anything related to you know
I said I'm here for you if you ever need
something you know she lives out here
now too so so what did you think when
her statement came out about being a
victim that's what that's kind of yes
one of the things like I mean obviously
it's a sense of subject now was it there
and I'm not her or whatever but you know
the fact that Corinne was like you know
I'm a victim and every is every girl's
worst nightmare whatever I mean so right
away I don't know who who's saying that
for her but it makes it look like that
she's saying I got sexually assaulted it
and you know with all party and saying
no that's not what happened and she
didn't say that happens it doesn't make
any sense it's confusing you know